un emballement qui a conduit à la mort
d'un professeur depuis ce lundi six
collégiens du collège du bois d'Olne
sont jugés à Paris pour leur implication
dans l'assassinat de Samuel paatti le 16
octobre 2020 que leur est-il reproché
cinq d'entre eux comparaissent pour
association de malfaiteurs âgé de 14 à
15 ans à l'époque des fait ils sont
accusés d'avoir désigné le professeur au
tueur en échange d'argent la 6e âgée de
13 ans pour dénonciation calomnieuse
c'est par elle que débute l'engrenage
elle a prétendu auprès de son père avoir
assisté à un cours pendant lequel Samuel
pti aurait montré des caricatures obsèes
que risque-t-il le procès se tient à H
clos jusqu'au 8 décembre les 6
adolescents risquent jusqu'à 2 ans et
demi de prison parmi les partis civiles
le ministère de l'Éducation nationale un
autre procès doit avoir lieu fin 2024 il
concerne les h suspects majeurs dont le
père de la jeune fille